whether it was the Gettysburg Address or
whether it was FDR's for freedom speech
they're all basically pointing back to
the declaration of dependence to remind
us and reignite as to why what we're
about to do go to World War two go to
Civil War is important for us to make
that sacrifice because we're upholding
these values upon which our company was
founded our country was founded
so absolutely they should be written
down because it makes us more
accountable right because somebody can
say we're not doing that and by the way
please don't write honesty on the wall
because if you have to write honesty on
the wall you have much bigger problems
right and we don't write what values
should be written on the wall is verbs
there are things we do values are things
we do like that innovation is not a
value right honesty is not a value right
and they're because they're not
actionable you can't walk into someone's
up and say be more innovative I don't
know what to do be more honest I didn't
think I was dishonest right but if we
write on the board always tell the truth
look at the problem from a different
angle give me something to do those are
values because values have to be
actionable they have to be doable but we
write them as these staid nouns on walls
and expect people to live our values I
don't know how to live innovation I
don't have to live value you know
provide value is that a calculation I we
spent less on partially hydrogenated
oils and high fructose corn syrup in our
ingredients is that bad you write so but
yes when well-conceived absolutely they
should be written down I'm a great
believer look at any great monotheistic
and polytheistic religion there was
usually a book
and that book is used for reference so
I'm a great believer in writing things
down I think company should have
manifestos that explain the vision they
have for the future world in which we
will exist which they will commit
themselves to help advance that has
nothing to do with their products or
their services barry-wehmiller that
makes manufacturing equipment says that
our we exist to build great people to do
extraordinary things we define success
for how we touch the lives of humans of
each other it's a manufacturing company
because it's not about the what they
make it's about using their company to
build people to do extraordinary things
and to value the success and measure the
success by how well they do that no
company you don't have a manifesto if
you're the only ones who care about it
and if it's based on your product your
service you're the only ones who care
about it right we're here to do the
things you don't want to do so that you
can do the things you wanted that's not
that's not nobody cares to provide the
best possible service and the lowest
possible price well often no one cares
like nobody reads that and goes I want
to work there you know but if you say we
exist to provide good clean family fun
to provide people to escape from reality
I want to work at Disney if you stand
here to challenge the status quo and
give the individuals the power to stand
up to Big Brother if you're that mindset
I want to work for Apple if you say were
to help we're here to help people be
more productive in their world I want to
work for Microsoft these are causes that
have nothing to do with their companies
they've just used their companies to
help advance those causes yes write it
down yes write it down and then make
sure that your people hold you
accountable to the things you wrote it
yes yes yes yes
[Music]
[Music]